winning the silver medal award and
alternative filmmaking we have Perry
janes with his films ugh perry figure
everybody has picked up on this by now
but we've rather specific instructions
before we're allowed to get up here to
the podium and give our thank you speech
I would like to thank as everybody has
with thanking the Academy for this
incredible honor as well as all of the
staff who helps to make the Student
Academy Awards possible rich Miller and
his entire team of people if possible
I'd actually like to give you another
round of applause for those who aren't
familiar you know this award brings
together a lot of really really talented
people as everyone tonight here has said
and I'm among the many things that have
made this week extraordinary including
you know many industry events and
meeting you know people around town just
having convened this group of filmmakers
and a lot of the opportunity to connect
among ourselves has really been a
special experience I want to thank
everybody involved with this film
there's too many people to name but a
number of them are here tonight I would
like to thank a couple people
specifically but first I would as other
people have like to ask anyone in the
audience who worked on the film to stand
and then get a round of applause
yourself as well
thanks guys for being sports about that
I had been asked not to make anybody
stand but among those people in the
audience tonight I want to thank on
Krista honi who has helped me with a
rigorous film submission you know
process I'd like to thank Benjamin del
my cinematographer for his command of
the moving image and I'd like to thank
my producer my creative collaborator my
friend and all-around life coach Tony
pishella without whom I would not be
here tonight I'd like to thank all of my
professors and mentors from the
University of Michigan chief among whom
is Terry saris my mentor my thesis
advisor my friend I'm very lucky to have
had her as a part of my formative growth
as a filmmaker and last but certainly
not least I need to thank my incredibly
supportive parents and girlfriend back
home whom have given me their unwavering
support as I have plunged boldly and at
times blindly into the life and career
of a working artist so thank you